サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
今日の法政の専攻をいたなさったのは石塚美佐子様でございます
で 美佐子様とご家族の方々
それから友人たち 皆様方に
仏法僧の御加護がありますように
すべての悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
健康で幸福に暮らせますようにと誓願いたします
お布施をすると心の煩悩がね
結構弱くなりますので
それはすごい徳とは言うんですね
ですから 解脱に達することができますように
それから皆様方のご先祖様にも必ず供養をしなくちゃいけないんですね
線香湯をするたびに先祖供養っていうものをしなくちゃいけない
日本の文化的にやっている先祖供養とは違ってね
そういうふうに考えると
私の両親がまだ元気でいるんだからね
供養するしかないよとかね
そう思うかもしれませんだけど
それはお寺でやっている葬式とは違ってね
我々は輪廻転生するとき
たくさん親戚のおかげ様で生活していたんですね
だから 両親だけではなくて
このまたたくさんね 先祖の方々がいるし
それから自分個人の輪廻転生の場合は
今と違った たくさん親戚たちがいるしね
無数にいるんですね 孤独を欲しくて
期待して だからまあ この孤独が先祖に回向いたしますと
先祖が幸福になりますようにと誓願いたしますので
皆様方も三回サード サード
サード では 今日のお話に入ります
自身マネジメントなんですね
あの なんかテーマが難しそうに見えるんだけど
今日は本当に面白いことにそんな難しくないんです
難しいと感じたら それは私のせいであって
テーマ自体は大したことないです
はい まあ論理的に入ってみましょう
すべては自分中心 なんか変な単語でしょ？でもそれは科学的な事実なんですね
なぜならば あの 今日 私の目がすごく悪くなっちゃって
何も見えなくなっている状態なんです
眼耳鼻舌身意で生命は色声香味触法という情報に触れてるんですね
情報が触れると 感じるんですね
目で感じる 耳で感じる
この感じることを我々あんまり気にしない
それから頭の中で何を見たか
何を聞いたかと合成するんですね
だからこの眼耳鼻舌身に触れるデータを合成した
あの知識自体が自分と思っているんです
大したことはないです
ついでに言いますけど
この自分自分実感 実感とかね
自我とかいうのは あの気づかない感覚のことなんです
だから我々仏教徒の感覚に気づいてみなさいと
それで自我の問題をいたって単純に解決します
ですから ちょっと余計な話でね
あの人は美しいと自分が言うのは正しくありません
なぜならば その人が美しいということは
証明された科学的な事実ではありませんよ
正しく言うならば あの人は美しいと感じる
そうすると あるいは思う
それは自分の方がことなんですね
だからあの人は美しいと言ったら
それはその人に関係ないんです
自分のことなんです 自分がそう感じたんです
あの人は関係ない だからそこはちょっと考えてみちゃうと
素晴らしいいろんなことがわかると思いますね
じゃああの人は私のことを恨んでいる
思って言っちゃうでしょ
それはその人のことじゃないんです
自分がそう感じちゃったんです
自分が感じたものはすべて現実正しいということはないでしょう
ある人は猫は大好きだと思っている
ある人は猫は大嫌いと思っている
だから誰の方が普遍的な真理ですかね
成り立たないでしょう
だからそれだけで人間の問題解決しますよ
自分というのは自分の感覚のことですよ
だから感じちゃえと はっきりと
感覚をちゃんと意識化して体験してみなさいと
そうすると この花は美しいとかね
私は裏から見ているんだからね
私の美しくは見えませんだけど
この花は美しいと思ったら
それはその人の感覚の問題なんです
山羊さんが来て あ これは食い物だと思ったら
これは山羊さんの感覚の問題なんです
山羊さんがベロで感じているんです
人間は目で感じているんです
だからそれだけ真剣に頭に入れておけば
生きる人間として起こる一切問題
そこで消えているはずなんです
それは俺の問題だと 次に
あるものはもう仕方がなく
あの人はもう気持ち悪いと感じてしまう
それで自分が苦しむ必要あるのかと
じゃあ苦しい だからといって
そんなことで苦しんでいいわけじゃないんだから
まあそんなただの感覚だからね
放っておけという感じで
次のことに進めばいいんです
気にしない ある人を見たら
なんか私のこと恨んでるみたいとかね
まあいいや それだけで終わっちゃうんです
実は それは自分の感覚だからだと
例えば電車で駅でね 例えばちっちゃなお母さんがお子さんがいて
お母さん抱っこしていると思いますよ
それでそのお子さんがもうおしゃべり屋である時期あります
結構何でも喋る その時自分を見て母ちゃん
あのおじいちゃんが気持ち悪いと言ったとしましょう
それでショックを受けちゃって
こちらはね 言われた人が
なんであの子供はそんなこと言うんです？なんでお母さん
自分の子供をね そんなこと言ったらあかんけど
しつけしないのかとかね
子供は性格が悪いし その上お母さんも性格が悪いんだと
それで家に帰ってもなかなか忘れられません
お布団に入っても なんだあの二人はね
それで苦しんだのは あのお母さんと子供
赤ちゃんですか？ないでしょ？自分でしょ
だから その赤ちゃんがそう感じてしまった
別にそれはそれでいいんじゃないんですかね
赤ちゃんがそれケロッと忘れちゃいますから
次の面白いものに目が行くんだから
そこで自分が耳で感じた
自分の感覚の問題なんですね
だから大したことないよ
みんな大げさにしてるんだけど
人生は膨大な本を書いたり
それでバカが病気にまでなるでしょ
もっとひどいバカがもう人殺しに戦争するまで行っちゃうでしょ
そんなことじゃなくて
いたって単純なことなんです
だからまあ それだけで今日の話はで終わりにしましょう
はい そういうことで この自分をマネジメントすることの第1ステップはそれです
世間に当たることをやめましょうと
この肉体で感じたことやと
これまた当てにならんでしょ
ある時 おにぎり食べて
そう 結構美味しいやとかね
ある時 その同じ店で買ったおにぎりを食べて
まあ大したことないとか
だから感覚もいい加減でしょ
例えば何かお菓子ちょっと食べて
あ これ結構美味しいなとかね
もう 1個食べようとしちゃうと
あれほど美味しくない
だから感覚も科学的じゃないんです
科学的っていうのはちゃんとデータでしょう
例えばある会社が作ったおせんべいがある
それは均等に作ることは当然です
それでおせんべいの半分食べたら
まあ結構気持ちよかったと
はい ポイントで言えば
10 10 あの 10 の 4 ポイントぐらい気持ちよかったと
ということは 残り半分食べたらまた 4 ポイントでしょ
だから 10点から 8 ですからね
喜びは かなり喜んでいるはずなんです
そこでもう一つせんべい食べて
また半分食っちゃうと
また 4 ポイントでしょ 8
かける4というとオーバーですね
あの楽しみは 10点までだからね
だから興奮はオーバーになっちゃって人は死ぬはずでしょ
死ぬんです でも 無理をして 3枚目のおせんべい食べたって死んだことはないでしょう
1枚目で十分であったのに
自分が無理をして 3枚目食べたと
死んだわけじゃないんです
ということは この科学的な計算には合わないね
感覚っていうのは全くいい加減
このいい加減っていうのは
皆様方の物理科学の立場からなんです
仏教は心の科学ですから
いい加減ではなくて そちらにそれなりのややこしい法則があるんです
物理科学と全く違うんです
物理科学は一本でつなげる単純なファンクションなんですね
10ML 水が入っているガラスに 15ML 水を入れたらどれぐらいになるかと足せばいいだけの話でしょ
そうするとこちらが減って
こちらが増えて いたって一直線で単純なんです
そこで複雑な科学もありますけど
数学もありますけど よくよく見るとすべてこのフラットで単純で考える世界なんです
あれは難しくなったのは
いろんな流れをつなげるだけで
そこでごちゃごちゃになっちゃって難しくなるだけで
心っていうのはそうじゃないんですね
心の法則はすごく違うんですから
物理科学とは違いますからね
例えばせんべいは美味しいと思うために
仏道の人は食べてみて
感覚を感じて判断するんです
そうすると おせんべいにあげられる味の感覚と塩の味やらいくつかの味でしょ
まあ 5種類しかないんですから
人間感じる味はね それはどれぐらいのバランスであるかとわかるだけで終わっちゃうんです
しかし 一般人にとっては
過去の経験と期待という心情も入ってきて
そこで構えるんですね
構えてデータが入れてみたら
構えたほどではない場合は自分で補って
また心から結果出すか
あるいはなんだ嫌ですというか
落ち込むか いろんな結果になるんです
だから心の底ではそういうことで難しくはなってますが
一応今日の自分を管理する方法で
第一はそういうことだから
いい加減な感覚にそんなに神経になる必要はないんです
おせんべい 1個食べてすごく美味しかったと言ったって
まあその時の話やと いい加減になる必要はないんです
はい それで次に人間の問題は
まあ俺は世界を知ってるんだというあの態度
それでこの世界は知ってるんですかね
六根というのは眼耳鼻舌身のことで
それは諸とも仏教用語で言いますけど
感覚から合成する概念
いわゆる現象ですね は
自分が知ってる外の世界です
面白いでしょう 私は世界のこと知ってるんだと思ったっても
自分の感覚なんです 自分が感じる世界なんです
世間は関係なくなっちゃうんです
共通知識を作るために苦労します
ですから 我々は学校やら友達やサークル作ったり
いろんなことをして話し合って話し合って
あれやこれや頑張って
この共通知識使おうと作ろうと頑張っているんです
これ 楽ちんじゃないんです
美味しいチャーハン作ろうと思ったら
チャーハンの作り方あるはあるわ
いろんなところに行って学ばなくちゃいけない
で まあ携帯でチャーハンの作り方ダウンロードして
それを見ながらやったら
これは一つの作り方で
その中でも最低 10個とか 20個ぐらいあるんですね
チャーハンの美味しい作り方やら
チャーハンの簡単な作り方やらね
ふわふわ感じるチャーハン作る作り方
あるいは硬く感じるチャーハンの作り方
豪華に見える じゃあいくらでもあるでしょうね
だからそういうことを学んで
学んで 学びまくっちゃって
苦労して お互いなんとなく似たような共通知識法を作ろうと
と頑張ってはいるんです
例えば 一部の人々は地球は丸いと言ってるんですね
我々は全然知らないね
正直なところ まあ偉い人は言ってるんだから
じゃあ丸いことにしましょうと
そこで丸いあれ 学校 子供たち
使うあれ あれ 何て言いますか
え？え？聞こえない あの普通あれありますね
それ作る人々は平らで作ってもいいんだけど
四角で作ってもいいんだけど
八角っていうのは やっぱり偉い人々は丸いって言うんだから
じゃあ丸く作りましょうと
そこでなんであれ斜めにして変でしょ？たまには斜めってないでしょ
なんか偉い人はそう言うんだからね
地球はちょっと斜めに曲がっているんだよ
それは嘘ですけどね 本当は
だってこれ丸いボールみたいなもんで
サッカーボールみたいなもんだからいいかな
もうボールみたいなもんでしょ
斜めにはならないね なんでそう言ってるかよくわからない
それなりの理由がありますけど
これ斜めと言ったことがちょっと問題なんですね
あれは地球の磁場のね
円覚をよく見たら まあそれは角度はあると感じたったんですね
太陽の光がこうやって九十度で当たっちゃうと
円極円極極はちょっとそれだけのことで
それはかわいそうに地球に文句言ってるんで
あなたは斜めに曲がってるんだよと
まあ人間の性格は斜めに曲がっているのはいいんだけど
地球に文句言ってどうかなと
まあとにかく それは我々の共通知識になっている
それのために我々は苦労したんです
幼稚園で 小学校で 中学校で
高校生で 大学で 大学院で
研究室ですごい苦労したんです
それでもうまくいってないね
なんとなく知ったようなつもりで
知らない方がいっぱいあって
電車の操縦士になりたくなれば
これかなり時間をかけて修行しなくちゃいけない
それで その人にバイオリンの練習する時間はないね
一生 それからなぜかというと
まあ責任任せたら 毎日出勤して仕事をしなくちゃ
終わって家に帰るとヘトヘト疲れていて
そうするとご飯食べてお風呂に入って寝る時間しかないんです
で また次の朝 また行かなくちゃいけない
そういうことで その人はすごい苦労して
人生全部かけて一つの共通知識を得たんです
たった一つ しかし 世界は電車の操縦士だけで成り立たないでしょう
ただ 電車だけ考えても
いろんな分野があるんだからね
あるはあるはもうきりがなくあるんです
はい ただ 皆さんは思ってほしいのは
私は知っている世界は私は世界
外の世界を知っているというのは怪しい
それは私は何を感じるのかということで
だからあんまりそれに執着して調子に乗らない方がいいんです
競争知識だよと思ったら
調子に乗りたくてほんのわずかしか得られない
ほんのわずか それだけは何の役にも立ちません
電車の操縦士にしたっても
たくさん専門家たちがそれぞれの仕事をしてくれないと
あるいは前に後ろに前に後ろに動かすことはできなくなっちゃうんです
うん はい それことで人間が変で
自分が世界を知ってると思ってるんですね
しかし 科学的に立証されていること柄について認めない人々がいるんです
面白いことは この科学的に苦労に苦労をかけていた共通知識も認めない馬鹿がいるんですよ
いまだに進化論は間違っていると
ドカンと神は人間を作ったんだと
それから動物などなどの世界を作ったと
真面目に信じている人もいる
だからそれはその人の世界なんです
何か古い頭イカれた人が書いた神話物語の本を読んで
この物語の世界は正しいと
まあしょうがない 子供たちと同じですね
子供たちは物語見たら
その世界に入り込んじゃうんですね
女の子は自分がシンデレラになっちゃうんですね
そこで店で売っている白雪姫のシンデレラのいろいろ道具を買ってきて
体につけていろいろやったりはします
でも子供はすぐそこ卒業しますけどね
そこで失敗する大人がいるんです
そういう大人がこのシンデレラ物語を死ぬまで持っていく
あの こういうストーリー
神話 物語 しかし 我々にはどうすることもできない
それはその人の世界です
その人の感覚の世界です
それは悪いと言っても聞いてくれないし
間違っていると言っても聞いてくれないし
自分が自分の感覚の世界に閉じ込まれているんだから
悪いという資格すらないんです
例えば進化論は間違っている
地球は平らであると 神がそうおっしゃっているんだから
これこそ事実だと言っている人に
私はあのね あなたは自分で作った妄想の世界に閉じこもっているだけやと
自分がいろんなところからそう感じただけでしょ
それやめろと言ったら
あのね あなたもそうでしょうと言ったらどうする？あなたもいろいろ科学本にあるものやらね
いろんなことをもう妄想して感じて
あなたは人間は進化したんだという妄想に陥っているんじゃないんですかと
あんた自分で知ってるんですかね？人間は進化したんですかと
知らないでしょ？だから結局お互い様でしょ
感情で作ったマイワールドは争いの元です
だから私は世界を知っているわけじゃないんです
英語で言えば I do not know the world, but I have my world created by myself.
そこで私はマイワールドに外のワールドだとラベルを貼っているので
This is the outside world, but in fact it is your inner world. これ
まあちょっと英語に言っちゃったんだから
ちょっと待ってください
意識入れ替えないと これって大きなプログラム間違いでしょ？だからそれ理解しましょう
直さなくていいんです
それで私はマイワールド知っている
お母さんはお母さんのマイワールドがあって
子供には子供のマイワールドがあるんですね
これ互い違うんだからぶつかりますね
いつでもぶつかります
お母さんがお風呂に入りなさいよと遅くなりますよと言って
ちょっと待って ちょっと待ってと
子供はゲームやっている
お母さん それは認めない
お母さんの世界では この時間でお風呂に入って
この時間でご飯食べて
この時間で連絡し合わないっていうマイワールドがあるんですね
子供には子供のマイワールドがあるんです
子供は飽きるまでゲームやって
それからしぶしぶお風呂に入って
それからドカンと寝る
また朝早く起きなくちゃっていうことは頭にないんです
あってももうもうずっと寝ているんです
これはそちらの世界 誰も間違ったことをやっているわけではないし
正しいことをやっているわけでもないんです
だから私たちは I live in my world ということを理解すれば
私は私が作った世界で生きているんだよと
あのスーパーに行っても
客観的なあるスーパーに行ったわけじゃなくて
自分が作った世界のスーパーに行っているんです
よく理解してください
いろんなところから ただ 20人の人々がスーパーに入る
そのその人は自分が見た自分のマイワールドのスーパーに入っているんです
みんな同じ経験をして
同じ気持ちになってスーパー出かけるは出て行くわけじゃないんです
大体私はもうスーパーに行きますけど
今はもうもう一人連れて行きますよ
体力ないんだから ビニール袋ぶら下がってもらうために
で その人は全部品のものをカゴに入れてくれるんだから
私はいろんな人のそれぞれの世界を見ているんですね
そうすると 私が何に興味を持って何を買うのか
そのその人々は何に興味を持って何を買うのかと
それぞれの世界が違うんです
例えば私の世界では 私は絶対買わないものはじーっと調べてみるんです
で スーパーにお酒のセクションあるんだけど
まあ中には入らないんだけど
まあどれぐらい値段かかるの？こんなものはどうかね
あ これ あ なるほど これはこれこれえらい高いとかね
高いってね 変でしょ？私は買わないんだからね
ですから しかし 他の方々は
例えば女性の方々はほとんどそのセクション見ようともしない
たまたま酒を買う男性たちがそこに入って
それだけ見て あれやこれや調べて
それを持ってきて買い物をする
野菜売り場には行かない
魚を売っているところには行かない
同じビルの同じフロアなのに
だからそれを見ても 私に感謝できることは
ああ 同じスーパーに行っても
私たちは自分の世界にあるスーパーに行ってくるんです
それわかる 忘れているんだから
我々は自己管理できなくなっちゃって
人と喧嘩する 人に当たる
マイワールドを相手に押し付けようとする
これは無理です 不可能です
できません  学校なんかに教えている先生たちとかね
まあ塾でやっている先生たちとかね
子供たちに何か理解してもらうためにどれほど苦労するのかと
これはウェル二つのぶつかりだから結構難しいんです
だから特に教師がデータを生徒のマイワールドに合うようにしてあげないと
子供は全部拒否するんです
これ大変でしょ 結構難しいんです
はい そこでポイント２が出てきたという
マイワールドというものがあるんだと理解する
だからそれは犬にも同じですよ
犬２匹飼ったからといって ２
匹の犬が二人仲良しっていうことはありえないんです
それぞれの世界があるんです
はい では 私たちはこの客観的な共通知識
これ知識の増えるということよりも
共通知識に入れ替える
交換する マイ知識は共通知識に交換する
商品券と同じで 一 自分の主観と合うものに賛成
やっていることはまたはちゃめちゃですよ
はい 勉強して知識を増やして世界を知るようにするそうで言っても
その人は自分の主観に合うものに
はい これ賛成 これ賛成
これ賛成と その方向へ行っちゃうんです
先生 治らないね その病気は
音楽好きな人は音楽の世界を探しているんです
絵を描くことが好きな人は
漫画描くことが好きな人は
その世界で知識を得て走り回るんです
それでマイワールドはより正しくなるわけじゃないんですね
2番目は 自分の主観を拡大強化できるものを足す
それを足すんです ギターを演奏できる若者が
ある人を見たら なんか違う技を持っている
ちょっと面白い音を出している
え？どうやってそれするのかと
そこで教えてもらって
自分もそれを練習して足すんですね ３
自分の意見に反対する意見を却下
だから音楽ばっかりやっている子供にお母さんがね
これやめて勉強しろ と却下
いたって単純に 四 自分の主観に反対する意見に攻撃することを考える
イスラム教の人々は キリスト教の人々をみんな殺して殺してあげなくちゃいけないんだと
それこそ神様に対する自分の敬意であると思っているんですね
反対意見を持っちゃうと殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
そこまでいかなくても
私たちも一応自分の意見と違う意見を持っている人々に対して攻撃をする
反対をする で サイトでいろいろ書く
その人ばかにして こう知らない世界を知りたいという気持ちがあるならば
知識を探し求める  それは悪口と言えないところ
五番目だけ ある人は まあ私だって知らないことはいっぱいあるんだと
では 知らないことを知ってやりますと思っちゃうと
それで知識が拡大していくんです
そこでも主観は働くんだけど
主観というのは本人が知っていることより知らない方が大きいんだと
という気持ちがあるんです
この科学者になっている人々は
大体いろんな発明する人々は
いろんな発見する人々は
そういうグループの人々なんです
知らないことは探し求めて知ろうではないかと
こういう人々は人類に新しい知識を提供して死にます
だから我々は学校で学ぶのは
人間が百年 約十年ぐらい苦労に苦労をかけて
一生研究して作ったものは
1分以内で勉強する すごいありがたいことです
真相の動きを勉強するために
今我々は人を殺す必要はないんです
ウサギを殺す必要はないんです
すべてできているんです
だから至って簡単に理解できる
うん そんなことで知識が増える
そこで問題が起こる これがポイントです
えーと 知識は結局主観になるので
簡単に感情と融合するんです
これが問題です 知識に見解に愛着が起こるんです
それが問題です 感情とは自分の好き嫌いの世界でしょ
それと知識は関係ないでしょ
でも我々は融合してしまうんです
それで知識見解っていうに愛着を作る
愛着を作るのは 私が世界を知ってるんだというあの幻覚からなんです
私は私 マイワールドに住んでるんだよと思ったら
別に愛着するのは恥ずかしくなるんです
ここで他人と争い 物別れ
悩み 怒り 落ち込みなどが生じてきます
これからひどい目に遭いますよ
セルフマネージメントする人は
知識と感情が混じれないように別々にします
あのプラスチック箱を 2つ持ってください
頭の中で これは感情 これは知識
合わせないでください
水と油と同じものです
全く違うんです 例えば
知識は水と同じもので
それほど危険性はないんです
感情は油と同じもので
ちょっと失敗でどうなるかわからない
燃えちゃいます 知識は水です
ですから 自分の油で燃えてくると
知識を使って火を消すことできます
自分が怒りで燃え出しちゃうと
自分自身の知識を使ってスプレーかけて消すことはできます
一般的にこれできなくなっているのは
全部同じ入れ物に入れているんです
水と油が一緒にはならんだけど
この場合は一緒になります
今例で思い出したのはドレッシングありますね
サラダの あれ いろいろドレッシング種類がありまして
油と液体がまるっきり分離しない
ものもありますね 和風ドレッシングの場合はだいたいバラバラになりますけど
それまた振って振って一緒にしなくちゃいけないんですね
まあ西洋系のドレッシングは全部一緒になってます
分解しません だから西洋系のドレッシングと同じです
知識と感情 最低和風のドレッシングにした方が
なんとかいいんじゃないかなと
なぜならば 昔私はこのドレッシング和風ドレッシングだったら油
みんなこれちょっと振ってください
私は絶対振らないで 油が返らないように下の液体だけ入れる方法があるのかとチェックするんです
そこで油が回ってくると
また前に上げてまた勢いをつけて
結構時間がかかります
周りにバカにされます
これ振っちゃえばいいのにとかね
でもそれはそちらの世界で
私は私の世界だから気にしません
セルフマネジメントは知識と感情
まあ箱を別々にしていてくださいね
はい もうさっさと次の一つ終わりまって
また同じポイントで出てきます
ちょっとテーマ変えてみます
自己管理 そんなに必要ですかね
自由に生きることは期待します
みんな面倒くさいね そんなのは
人間に自由がないのかと
なんで俺には俺の生き方で生かしてくれないのかと
なんで自分のことを放っておいてくれないのかという訴えがあるでしょ
それに仏教の答えがあります
無明が活かされるエネルギーです
世界世間の人々はそれ知らなかったんです
インド人が神の力でみんな生きてると思っていたんです
神が一生懸命生命を動植物全部生かしてあげているんだと
それ聞いたらですよ 俺だったら間違ってでも神にはなりませんだって
大変な仕事でしょ？みんな生かしてあげなくちゃかんだからね
立場がない ですね それでかじめ
神っていうのは惨めな存在だと
その一言を理解しないで神を拝む
まあそんなのは妄想だからどうでもいいんだけどね
お釈迦様はそのヒントもあって
生命は生かすエネルギーって何なのかというと発見したんです
無明です いわゆるどんな生命にも物事を客観的に見る能力がありません
自分に見える世界は自分の主観でしょ
自分に聞こえる世界は自分の主観でしょ
自分が考える世界は自分の主観でしょ
この壁は破れないんです
うん お釈迦様は破ったんです
この壁に無明というんです
壁っていうのはちょっとした文学的な言葉で
これは壁という物質的なものじゃないんだよね
なぜ私には私に見える世界
聞こえる世界 自分が味わう世界
自分が感じる世界 自分が考える世界があるんです
だから何しようとも この 6つのカテゴリーの中に入ってしまうんです
だから知っても知っても知っても主観です
どうにもならない あの魚にこのね
あの 美味しい何か食べさせようと思って
これ汚れた水に入っちゃうと味が悪くなるんですね
といっても 魚に食べさせますかね
何をあげても 全部あの魚が住んでいる水の中に入って
水と溶けて水が入ったものを食べているんですね
あのケーキも好きな魚がいるんですよ
ケーキっていうのは ちょっと水にディップして食べちゃうとまずいでしょう
だから自分が飼っている魚さんだから
昔 私の器にでっかい魚がいたんです
ケーキは大好物です それで私もあの
これディップしない方がいいやと
水が汚れているしね で
魚とすごく仲良くなって
だからもう言っちゃうと
これあげますよと言っちゃうと
体が上に出すんですね
出して口を開けたら口に入れちゃうんです
私の方が重い 魚 ズクッて中に入って飲む
食べるんで もうダメだこれはと言ったら聞いてくれない
あれを口に取った途端
水の中に入って だから難しいですよ
もうだから我々人間であろうが
すべての生命が知りたい知りたいと真面目に思っている生命もいます
インドでもたくさん宗教家たちが修行者たちがいて
その中で真面目な人もいたんです
珍しいんですけどね 宗教っていうのは認識に決まってるんだけど
しかしたまたま真面目な方々もいるんですね
じゃあ真面目に修行するとかね
でもこの壁は破れないんです
経典を読んでみると このサマーディとかね
瞑想のこととかね なんで仏教はこのサマーディ世界
一般人が神秘世界という世界は
お釈迦様は心理学的に科学的に説明したのかというと
この壁を破ってもらうためなんです
はい 無明は貪瞋痴などの感情として働く
ということは 皆様に無明があると皆様が知らないんです
皆様が怒ったら知ってますね
欲が出たら知ってますね
いい加減な気持ちになったら
それは知ってますね どうでもいいやというね
投げ捨てる気分になったら知ってるでしょ
それは貪瞋痴です 無明は貪瞋痴として働くんです
それから無明は存在欲
仏教用語で渇愛を作って生命を支配します
我々は無明は知らないんだけど
死にたくないだけは知ってますね
だから渇愛は知っている
あんた死にたくないと思うのはバカバカらしいでしょと言っても
何言うの？あなたはという態度を取るんです
だってみんな死ぬんだから
でも死にたくないでしょ？あまりにも変でしょ
誰だって死ぬんだから
私の番はいつ来るのかい？とか考えた方がいいのに
人間は誰でも私はいつ死ぬでしょうとか考えたことはない
たまにお医者さんが言うんです
あんた まああと半年ぐらいで意識で亡くなるでしょ
怖くなっちゃって それでわかるでしょう？どれぐらい存在欲が渇愛があったのかと
どれほどの無明な人かと
それでなんで私に限ってこんなことになるのかと言った人には
まあ将来はあまり赤信号です
死後もあまりにも無明
癌です 半年です あ そう
なるほどと変えればいいでしょうにね
私もそれ知りたかった
いつ死ぬのかと これから計画立てます
だって半年ありますからね
すべて余計なことをやめて
半年でできることだけにしますと
言った方がとってもありがたい話でしょうね
宣告っていうのは まあ無明だからね
そうならない 生きられるなら何でもやるという気持ちになります
どんな人でも生きなり生きられるなら何でもやる
今日朝 私はすごく目が痛くて
もう見えない状態で 半分もうどうしようもない状態いたんですね
で それでいろいろお釈迦様のお手前をおしょうしながら
まあ何かくだらんことを考えると目が気になっちゃうと面倒くさいんだからね
いて くだらんことをわざと考えたんですね
何を考えてもドラキュラのことを考えたんです
ドラキュラ 皆様ご存知ですね
日本語で吸血なんとかって言うんですね
ドラキュラっていうのは人の血を吸うんですね
男のドラキュラは女の血を吸う
女のドラキュラは男の血を吸う
そこでこのまあ馬鹿げた話ですけど
映画の世界でね あるいは漫画の世界であるね
そこで面白いことは それを読む人々は
映画を見る人々はどう思うかというと
ドラキュラって残酷です
怖いんです あの あれ ステーク何だったっけ？釘でしたっけ？木のあれで心臓を通して刺さなきゃ刺して殺さなくちゃいけないよと
ドラキュラは十字架を見ると怖がりますよ
だから十字架ぶら下げて
映画の世界はそうなっているんです
そこでそれを馬鹿にして
時々ドラキュラが家に入ると
ある人は十字架を見て入るなよと言ったら
ドラキュラそうと言って十字架をとってピシッとつぶったりする映画もあります
で 本人どれぐらい馬鹿怖がるのかと
そこで私が思ったのは
そういうストーリーではなくて
ドラキュラの物語 映画を見る我々は
ドラキュラが完全悪 悪い
殺す べきやと思っている
ドラキュラは何の悪いことをしたんですか？と考えたんです
何もやってないんです
ただ 誰かの血を吸うだけでしょう
それでも血を吸われる人は痛くて
ああ それはない すごい気持ちよくなるんだそうです
ものすごい快感を味わうんだそうです
ストーリーでは それではそのドラキュラ
何の悪いこともしていないんです
何であんな風にドラキュラはこれにしているのかと
それで このドラキュラ殺すべき
殺すべきだと言っている人々は
たくさん生命を殺して丸ごと食べているんです
なのに自分たちがいい人々なんです
ドラキュラは殺さないんです
ある程度血を吸って人を置いておくんです
そこでドラキュラたちの一人たくさんありまして
ドラキュラのたちの世界で犯罪者がいるんですね
私はこの大体いろんなストーリーをまとめて今喋ってます
このドラキュラたちの世界でいるドラキュラたちも認めない
裁くべき犯罪のドラキュラっていうのは
人の血を吸ったら全部吸い吸ってしまって
もう死ぬまで吸うと これは道徳違反だと
いうあれ なんとか子供たちが喜んで読むストーリーシリーズだったんですね
今忘れているんです 本シリーズの私の部屋にもあるんだけど 12
冊ぐらい ダレンシャンという名前で
あれも偽名ですけどもね
書いているストーリーなんですね
どこかオーストラリアかどこかで
なんか人が子供 若者が来てね
まあ私の部屋に入って
ダレンシャンの本を見て
あ あんなあ ダレンシャンと言って行っちゃってね
読んでますよと言ったら
仲間にしてくれたんです
はい そちらではもう悪いドラキュラがいて
良いドラキュラ ドラキュラの世界で
はい そこでその人間っていうのは変っていうのはそういうことなんですね
自分たちも動物を殺して殺して殺しまくって食べているのに
一度たりともかわいそうやと残酷やと思ったことはないんですね
しかし ドラキュラにこれ期待する
血を吸うことはけしからんやと思ってくださいと
何考えてるんですかね
だから人間の愚かさっていうのは
どこを見てもあるんだ
ああいうありえない子供向けのストーリー世界でも
そもそも人間だから それ書くのは
どんなストーリーもその屁理屈ところがあるんです
ですから 生きられるならば何でもやるという生き方で我々は生きているんです
ドラキュラ悪い なぜならば
自分の生きることにはちょっとやばい
それだけ 血を吸われたらまずいと
あれって肉体に対する愛着でしょ
でも日本の病院関係でね
献血してくださいと言ってるんだけど
誰もやらない あれってすごい汚いやり方でしょ
あの献血室にみんな若者
元気な人々が行かないことは
日本で体が病気で献血できない人も年寄りは当然できませんし
結構みんなにできるでしょうに
やらない それぐらい肉体に愛着
生きていきたいという
無明の だから無明が道具を使ってそこでいじってるんです
人を 感情は自己破壊 他を破壊の結果になるし
寿命さえ全うすることができなくて
失望感に陥ります そういうことで
例えばそういうもう何でもやって生きてみるぞと見た人のには
寿命を全うすることはできませんよ
早く死んじゃうんです
本当は早く死にたくないんです
できることなら 150 年も生きていきたいんです
しかし そういう人々はだいたい 40歳で 50
歳で死にます そうすると失望感があんまりです
年取ってクタクタになっちゃって
もう歩けもなくなっちゃって
もう食べることもできない
で まあしょうがない 死んだ方がマシやと思う人の死希望感はそんな強い子はないんです
覚悟しても復興できませんと
はい そういう生き方をする
はい それで無明が生かされるエネルギーだと理解しましょう
これで革命的な真理です
神が偉大なる神 無量無制限の慈しみ
憐れみを持っている神が生かされていると言ったら完璧嘘ですね
だって世界はそんな感じじゃないでしょ？残酷でしょ
生きることは なのに愛着があるから
存在欲あるから 無明があるから
嘘正しいと思っちゃうんです
この間 事務所で鉄郎さんにちょこちょこっと喋った面白いことがあって
シンデレラ物語ででね
シンデレラが魔法で作った衣装でおじ様と遊んでるでしょ
12時になると魔法は消えるんです
シンデレラも慌ててさっさと逃げるんだ
12時になる前に 鐘が鳴り始めればさっと消えちゃうんだけど
ガラス靴だけ残っちゃうんですね
走っちゃったんだから
死んだら服が全部なくなって
召使の服に変わったんだけど
ガラス靴一つだけ なんで変わらな消えなかったんですかね？変でしょ
だってあの 誰か魔法作ってあげた人が 12時までだと決めたんだから
だったらいっぺんに消えるはずなんですね
で みんなシンデレラ物語喜んでるんだけど
あれには気づかないね
あのちょっとした矛盾ね
ということは やっぱり存在欲がありまして
無明でもう感情を作って作って生きていきたいんですよ
だから理屈崩れても気にしない
自己管理は最強の戦い
なんか結論あると思いますよ
自己管理は 生命は感情がない
生命は感情の奴隷です
全然見えない ただの生き物です
自己 管理なかったら だって無明の奴隷でしょ？感情の奴隷でしょ
感情には理屈ないでしょ
だからドラキュラは悪くて自分がいいでしょ
うん 皆感情で 感情でではないかな
感情を賛嘆している では間違ってますよ
感情を え？え？ 一言抜けました
自己管理とは本物の自分と
あ なるほど 自己管理とは本物の自分と対立して戦うことなんです
だから 思うほど簡単じゃないんです
私は簡単にそうと喋っていたんだけど
本物の自分と戦わなくちゃいけないんです
本物の自分というのは
無明と渇愛 存在欲と貪瞋痴と汚いものばっかりなんです
皆 感情を賛成している
リアルセルフ セルフ ジェニュインセルフ
本来の自分とは暗黒の塊です
皆様 今まで読んだ本なんかでは
本物の自分に出会いましょうとかね
えらいことを言っていますでしょ
ファインドユアジェニュインセルフと英語で書いているテキストなんかはね
こいつらどこまでバカかとわからない
ジェニュインセルフというのは悪の塊
暗黒の塊なんです 無明なんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想もいくらか進んでいくと
結構負けます みんな リアルセルフ見えてくるんです
それでびっくり えーっと怖くなっちゃって瞑想やめるんです
かわいそうに 戦いとは
本来の自分を智慧の光で置き換えること
戦いと言っても このキリスト教
イスラム教で言っているような
武器を持って人を殺すことじゃないんです
心の中にある本来の自分がある
無明の自分 感情の自分を智慧という光に置き換えるんです
無明が暗闇にたとえると
暗黒にたとえると そちらに光をあげるんです
だから自己管理っていうのは難しいということも理解してください
はい それで私がポイントは自己管理必要だと
疑問するなよと 生命は無明で生きているんだよと
怖いんだと このままなら
自己破壊と破壊に行くんだよと
地球丸ごと破壊したでしょ
今 北極の全部グレースはもう溶けてるんです
もうどうしようもないんです
最近ニュースでね あんまりにもマンモスな氷の塊が解けましたと
だから海の水位が上がるでしょうに
海に住んでいる生命にもはちゃめは
誰がやったのですか？人間がやったんです
科学者にも自己管理がない
そこで地球温暖化問題というのは
一人一人の生命の責任なんです
誰も気にもしない 我々はある時間
地球でのおかげで 地球と母親の栄養をとって生きてきたんだから
殺して帰る しかし それはもうアメリカは大反対ね
温暖化には ソ連は全く反対
中国は全く反対 インドは反対終わり
第三世界 それやってくださいとアメリカが言うんです
第三世界はそんなに温暖化になってないし
アマゾンの森は企業たちで壊しているでしょうに
アメリカの企業でしょうに
アメリカでハンバーガー食べるために
南アメリカで森を全部切ってしまって
牛を飼っているんです
南アメリカの人々じゃないんで
やっているのは そういうことで
人間というのはいかに残酷かと
その上 残酷であることに気づかない
だから私はこういうふうにしゃべるんだけど
私は変人ですね 本当のこと言うと変人です
それで私は落ち込んで下がると思ってはいる
私にはどうってことないです
何ぐらいだっても えーとですね
はい 次のセクションは逆流を進む
ですから この自己セルフマネージメントというのは
この逆流なんです 流れ 2つ
1 物質の流れに心の流れ
無知な人は真剣に物質の流れに逆らって惨めに負けるんです
俗世間の道です それは
例えば台風が来ると 台風に構えるわ
構えるわ 構えるわ で 負けるでしょ
被害はひとくした 構えすぎちゃって
いくらかまあ人が怪我することを死ぬことはもう極力少なくなっただけで
だけどその人はまたやがて死ぬんだからね
そのうち死にますよ あの水害どうやって止める？で
頑張るでしょ すごい苦労しているでしょ
だから我々は飛行機作るわ
新幹線作るわ あらゆる機械作るわ
これは物質を作るに逆らっている
例えば 遠いところにいる人と喋れないんですね
これは気に入らないんです
感情があるんだから 欲があるんだから
だから遠いところにいる人とどうやって喋ればいいのかと考えたところで
もうベルさん始め グラハムベルはじめ
それからもう今 最近の携帯まで進んじゃったんですね
それで今の携帯では知り合いとしゃべるだけではなくて
世界ともコンタクトできるという
もうSNSシステムができているんですね
それ俗世間の道 仏道は心の流れに逆らうんです
仏道は心の流れに逆らうんです
物質の流れには逆らえません
意味がないんです 例えば
老いないようにアンチエイジングっていうね
あのいろんな薬やらホルモンやら食っちゃったからといって年取りますよ
だったら潔く年取れば気持ちいいのに
意味がない 死なないように何か遺伝子組み換えできるのかと研究しているんです
バカでしょ そこでもし人の体の遺伝子組み換えちゃって
死なない体 なったらどれほど危険になるかと
どうでもいいんで あんなのは
だって無明だから 生まれてくる人が死んで死んでいくことはいかにありがたいことかと
知らないんです そこで我々は心の流れに逆らってみる
たまに負けちゃうこともありますよ
例えば 怒らないように気をつけても
あ 怒っちゃったということもあり得る
欲張らないようにしちゃうんだけど
やっぱりやっちゃったとかね
まあそういう失敗たまにあるんだけど
必ず勝てる 心の流れには勝てます
自由もあります はい そこでまたガクンと心の流れに勝てるところ
ちょっと説明しましょう
前のスライドで例えば怒ることは当然自然です
美味しい食べ物を見たら食いたくなるのは自然です
心が食えと言ってるんです
心は体に聞かない 体に栄養必要ですか？と聞かない
食えと 気に入らないと心が判断した人に対して怒る
怒ったらあなたは損しますよということは言ってくれない
無明だから だから怒ることを落ち込むこと
自然です いたって簡単です
司会すること 恨みを持つこと
人を呪うこと 罰が当たれとかね
いうのはいたって自然です
それは心の流れです そこで逆行するんです
怒らないように 結構難しいんです
後でその説明があると思います
はい 自己と自我の差 自己とは眼耳鼻舌身意で色声香味触法に触れる
触れるとき起こる感覚の流れです
あの自己っていうのは流れるんですよ
だって言葉は聞こえる
聞こえるたびに自己が変わって変わって流れる
ものを見る見る見るたびに
自分も変わって流れる
だからチャネル六つでしょ？だから自己っていうのは六種類なんです
全部すーっと電子計光版みたいにピピピッと流れるんです
光ったり消えたり 光ったり消えたり
この流れをひとまとめにして自己という
あの互い違う六つの流れなんです
それをひとまとめで言葉で自己と言うだけで
本当は自己というものはないんですが
自分という実感が決して変わらない本物の実体だと勘違いすることは自我です
俺は絶対変わりませんと言っちゃうと
相当の無明な人なんです
それが自我なんです だから十年前で怒られて馬鹿にされた人は
十年経っても覚えて怒って自分を燃やしているんです
あれは自我があるからなんです
十年前だから その人はもう想像できないほど変わっている
自分も想像できないほど変わっている
はい どれぐらい変わるの？例えば皆様
音の周波数知ってるでしょ
あれって例えば megahertz だったら
1 秒間に二十万回かな
変化するでしょ それぐらい速さで自分も変わるんです
見る時の波長違うし 嗅ぐ時の波長また違うし
味わう時の波長はそれぞれ波長違いますよ
ですから お互い一緒にはならないんだけど
それそのスピードで自分が新たに生まれるんです
新たな自分 新たな自分
いい俺が生まれる時は俺は俺だよと思ったら
もう救いようがないんです
平気で言うんですよ 生まれたのは赤ちゃんでしょうに
死んだでしょうに 荒川を見て
この荒川はもうもう千五百年前からあるんだけど
冗談でしょ？荒川の寿命っていうのはほんの秒秒で終わっちゃいます
すると別な水が流れるんです
六根に対象が触れるたびに自分が変わるのだと理解すると
問題は解けます だから皆様に自己管理のマネージセルフマネジメントの鍵を教えます
いつでも自分が変わるんだと
六種類の自分があって
その時その時一人が優先です
それだけ ものを見る時はその自我自己が優先です
聞く時はその自己が優先です
映画を見ている場合は
もう見る自己と聞く自己が交代でザーッとやっているんです
音楽を聴く場合は 聴覚だけの自己で流れるんです
だからいつでも六種類の自己があって
あまりにも激しく流れるんだから
この流れるところはもう肉体の中で起こるんだから
一つまとめて自分というだけです
ですから皆様 その問題解決至って単純です
流れるんだと 例えば人に
え？昨日あんたね こういうこと言った
ああ  それ昨日の私 今日私は違いますと
それだけです 皆様 それを借金に使うかもしれませんだけど
この技は あんた 一年前
十万円私から借金したでしょ
ああ 一年前の私でしょ
今は違いますと 今の私は借金していないんだ
あなたから 本当でしょうねと
本当です 借金したのは十年前の私です
今の私はあんたのような人から借金しないよ
まあそういう でも 日常生活の中で我々
恨み 憎しみ 嫉妬持ちあふれんだから
それで体が燃えるんだから
いつでも瞬間瞬間 自分が違うと覚えておいてください
問題は解けます 自我の問題は
自我って病気です どうしても行くでしょ
変わらない自分がいると思ったら
あまりにも無明が反乱を起こしているでしょ
少女色声香味触法が触れると動揺する
もう揺らいでいるんです
だって妄想で変わらない自分と石のようなものがあると思っているんだけど
ないでしょ だから情報触れるとこれ揺らぐしかないんです
良いと思ったら欲に溺れる
悪いと思ったら怒りに溺れる
無明から起こる感情に世界を合わせようとする
これ 3行目理解してください
私たちは自我の病気だから
自分の気持ちに世界を合わせようとする
それは大きな問題ですけど
すごい可愛い例で説明します
例えば 人間が花は綺麗やと思うんですね
でも自然の花の美しさは物足らないね
そこで自分の欲望に合わせて花を育てて
こんなものを作るんです
花を生けるんです 生けるじゃなくて
あれは花を殺すなんです
そこでどうせ人間っていうのはあべこべだから
花を生けると言うんです
本当に殺しているのに
なんで花を生けるという文化が開始したのかというと
人間の知覚で欲を作って
その欲に世界をいじる
だから食べやすい 甘さがある
カボチャ キャベツを作る
歯触りのいいリンゴを作る
種のないブドウを作る
と それで自然も破壊する
そういうものを食べたら栄養になるかならないか
それはもう気にもしない
温暖化の問題と同じです
それと大きい問題ですね
目から入ってくる世界を合わせをする
だから 家族の中でも奥さんが自分の感情によって旦那を管理しようとする
うまくいくわけないでしょ
旦那が自分の欲望に合わせて奥さんを管理しようとする
それっていかに残酷かと理解してないんです
自分の欲望 プログラムに人を合わせるということは罪でしょう
これ人権 尊厳破壊している
犬たちを見たらよくわかるでしょ
犬たちはどれほどひどい目に遭っているのかと
足が短いやつがいて 足が長いやつらがいて
毛がものすごい長い犬がいて
いろいろ はあ 近い世界はある
個人の気持ちに これどうやって読むんですか？克服とは
ありえないので 自分に火をつけて泣き叫ぶような結果です
我々は結局は 例えば奥さんが旦那を自分のプログラムに合わせると
奥さんには泣く人生が結果になるんです
旦那さんが奥さんを自分の気持ちに入れ替えようと思っちゃうと
お互い決して仲良くしてくれない
自分の心を開いてくれない
全く得体の知れない人と一生を過ごすことになるんです
よくありますよ 男たちは自分の奥さんが何者かと 20年経っても知らないんです
だから自分で自分に火をつけて泣くんです
あー燃えてる あー焼いてる
あー痛いとかね 勝手にしろよと
答えは 次に逆らってみる
見に行きます 怒鳴られたら笑ってみる
反対の反動でしょ 馬鹿者と言われたらありがとうと言ってみる
それで全部言う時間ないんです
ですから テーラワーダ仏教協会の日常60なんたらなんたら経典で
67ページにはサッレークスッタという経典があります
それでいかに逆らってみなさいと
お釈迦様が比丘たちに明確に教えた経典の短いバージョンです
項目だけ そこにテキストにあるんで 40項目あります
プロブレムコンペティション
これというのは比較するときの起こる問題ですね
それはみんなやってる
失敗なんですね 勉強していない
ただいい加減に比較する
自分と他人を正しく比較する方法はあるんです
皆自我で自分と他人を比較するんです
これは話にならない 自我自体が病気でしょ？だから自分程度の気持ちでいいんです
すべては煩悩が爆発的に現れる
例えば自我で比較すると
自分の中で心の中で爆発が起こるんです
煩悩の爆発 火山の噴火よりも怖いんです
固定した自分がいないならば
固定した他人もいないんですよ
だから自我っていうのは固定した自分でしょう
変わらない自分 そうすると
例えば人を見ると結構美しい
自分が固定しているでしょう
自分が醜い 嫉妬が出てくる
嫌な気持ちになる ある人はそうではなくて
ああ なんて美しいかて
そのその人を自分のものにしようとする
どちらでももう煩悩が爆発しちゃったんです
人が自分に怒鳴る 固定した自分だったら
いわゆる自我だったら
なんで私に怒鳴るのかと
瞬間瞬間変化する自分だったら
なるほど 今のこの間でこういうこういうことになったんだから
その結果だよと それだけですね
で 試しに比較しても それはその場限りの結論です
はい 正しく自己で自我ではなくて
自分は変化する流れ川
だからその川は別な川を観察する
でもすぐ流れますからね
こちらの川はあの川って超怖いなと思う
判断する するとこちらの川が変わるでしょ
あちらの川も変わってるんですね
だから固定したアイデアにならないんです
あの川が怖いっていう風に結論付けることはできません
ある瞬間で怖くなっただけ
はい そういうことで 人と人を比較しても
その場その場限りのことで
これ役に立たない 人を理解したことにもならない
ある人は自分を怒鳴ったからといって
その人は怒りの塊 性格の悪い悪人であると決めてくることはできないんです
その場であんた怒っている
あんたやっていることは性格悪いと
その場で言えば構いませんよ
場離れたら終わり 場が離れたその人は自分の子供を抱っこしてね
可愛い可愛い 今日は何か食べちゃったの？とかね
アイスクリームでも買ってあげようかなとか
親やってるかもよ だからその場で
変わるんです 人格は退化して精神病にもなります
間違って比較すると人格は退化します
だから精神病はみんなそうでしょう
私はよくわかることは
もう人々は私の悪口を言ってるんだという病気があるんですね
ありえないでしょ 人々は他人に構う構える暇がないんです
で そこで家の３階に住んでいて
バス停に二人見てしゃべっているの見えるでしょ
私の悪口言っていると
言うと 隣の人はあのね
聞こえないでしょうに
あなたに聞こえないんだけど
私に聞こえますよと言うんです
どれほど病気かと 実際
そういうケースいくらでもあります
まだ高いところ 怖いわ
まあまあ それはちょっと別な原因もありますけどね
閉鎖恐怖症とかね いろいろ
まあそれは時々遺伝子的にも
それは過去の原因もありますね
過去の業の場合もね でもまあ
それでもちょっと理性使ったらね
狭いところに入ったからといって死にはせんにゃと
自分の燃えた火を自分の知識の水をかけて消すこともできますけどね
そこで正しいっていうのは
人を比較してもいいよ
その瞬間だけにしてください
持ち運ばないでください
ある時 あなたは素晴らしい人だと判断した人は
ある時は悪い人にもなります
当たり前でしょ 夫婦は離婚もするでしょ
結婚した時はどうですかね
この人と一緒なら死んでも悔いはありませんと
あれ それからこの人と一日も一緒に生活したくないんだと
私ではなくて こいつは死んだ方がいいやと
そういうところまで変わるんですよ
それで離婚してみたら
やっぱり私はやりすぎでしたかなと
また変わるんですね はい
正しい比較 １ 自分とは瞬間の存在
相手も同じです 両方の役に立つように比較してみる
いろいろ会議で議論する時でも
いつでもその瞬間だけやと
それで相手が自分の意見を批判したからといって怒る必要ない
まあいいよ まあいい結論に達しましょうよと
それであなたの意見は何ですか？あなたの意見は何ですかと
そうやって自分の意見と言い換くせて
結論に立ったら はい さようなら
終わりと そこで終わらなくちゃいけないです
自分の一時的な判断は相手のすべてではないので
自分の判断のレベルを相手の背中に貼らないで貼らないこと
みんなやってます それは他人にラベル貼っちゃうんです
この人は可愛い この人は可愛くない
この人はうるさい この人は気持ち悪い
この人は私のことを怒って
怒っている 恨んでいるとかね
ラベル貼っちゃって ずっと変化する人間は変化しない人間にしちゃうんです
自分勝手で 苦しみの部分です
だからそれは自我で比較するとそうなるんです
じゃあ実効で比較しましょう
問題ないんです 実効で比較すると
あんた本当に悪人ですねって言ってもいいんです
その時だけ 次の日はあんた本当にいい人ですねと全く違うことを言っても構いません
あのね あんた昨日私に悪人がと言ったでしょ
言ったよ なんで今日はすごいいい人やと言うんですかね
あんた変やと いい 変じゃないよ
昨日のあちらにいた人は本当に悪人でしたからね
今こちらの人は本当にいい人でしたからね
ですからね だから合ってますよ
それだけです いかに自由な世界が現れるんですかね
ものすごい自由な世界が現れるんです
判断する中ではないんです
この無常の流れですからね
判断もその瞬間だけ  です
えーと このステップは難しいと思うならば
人を判断することは一切やめましょう
こんな風に瞬間瞬間で判断して
もうすべてきれいさっぱり忘れるというのは難しい
私には だったらやめてくださいですよ
しかし 判断することをやめてください
それで二 業の法則で他人を見る
各生命は自分の特有の業で生きています
自分は自分の業で管理されています
業って業だけですよ 自分のものっていうのは
それは生きるエネルギーの方向を決めるんですね
例えば うどんもあって
ラーメンもあって おそばもある
どちらにする？で 業はうどんにした方がいいんじゃない？というふうに微妙に傾くんです
それで何のことなく じゃあ私はうどん食べますと
これ 自分の業の結果であることは
なぜあなたそば食べなかったんでしたね
かわいそう あんたはと言ったっても
本人にとってはしょうがないんです
そんな私はうどん好きだからね
それで終わるんです そういうことで
誰にも自分特有の業があるんです
その業 私には入れません
私の業はその人にも入れません
例えば 私の業で演歌を聴くと
なんか暗くなって気持ち悪くなるんです
だから音楽を聴くのは
ちょっとしたいい気分になるためでしょ
私は演歌はダメだと私は思ってますけど
皆さんもそうなる必要はないでしょ
皆様に関係ないんです
それは私の業です 覚悟が違うので人は様々です
だから決して自分に似ている人を探す必要はないんですね
いないんです そこで この我々にとっては
自分より美しい人がいる
自分よりすごい能力ある人がいる
10歳なのにプロのピアニストもいる
で  10歳なのにプロの歌手になって
ものすごく曲を歌う子供もいる
自分の国でもいる それを見てもね
私に関係ない それはその子供の業です
だから目が見えない人がいる
なんてかわいそうな人です
思っちゃうと悪業なんです
それは 女神ね 別に それで終わり
喋れない人がいたら 自分は手話をわからないんだからね
困っちゃったんだけど
まあなんとか別にという感じでやりとりすればいいでしょうに
それぞれの業なんですよ
本人にもどうすることもできない
例えば喋れない人がいるというのはね
聴覚が壊れているでしょ
喉がいいんですけど 喋れない
だからまあその人に何かできるというにもできない
時々日本ではね その人々にも喋られるようにするんです
でも本人が喋ってるんだけど
本人の声は本人に聞こえない
だからすごい音が変なんですね
発音も変なんです 変というのは失礼なんですけど
我々普段喋っている言葉とはちょっと違うんですね
で 私はそれを見て よく頑張ってるな
この人はとかね 自分で自分の音も聞こえないのに喋ってるんだよと
それでこちら喋ったら
その人は口と顔であれで判断するんです
音で判断しない だから考えてみればすごい能力でしょ
だから業で見ると結局はみんな平等さまで
自分の生き方を自分には変えられないのに
相手の生き方を変えようとする無駄であり得ない努力を中止
業で見ると これいたって簡単で
まあ業は変えられません
いろいろ面白いことあるんですよ
もう チキンはカレーだったら食べるんだけど
フライドチキンは気持ち悪くて食べられないとかね
同じものですけど 変でしょうと
食べなさいと 意味がないんです
フライドポテトなら食べるんだけど
スマッシュポテトは嫌ですと
しょうがないでしょ こちらいくつで同じものだから
言っても意味がないんです
はい 理性のある人 知恵のある人
性格の良い道徳的な人をサンプルにして相手にある
しかし 自分にはない徳を身につくように励む
だから 他人と自分を比較するならば
自分より立派な人と比較してください
この勇気を持ってください
あいつアルコールならもう飲んでどうしようもない人が全くアルコールを飲まない人と仲良くしてみてください
大変だけどね それで自分の人格が向上するんです
だから そういう仲良しグループでの場合は
いつでも自分には立場がないんですよ
ただ すごい道徳的な人がいる
自分が道徳にはだらしない
その人と仲良くすると
いつでも自分の立場がないんですね
それでいいんです それで自我が牙出しません
人間のこのシステムは良くないんです
俗世間の自分に支配できる人々を仲間にするんです
恐ろしいです 目上の人のアドバイスを受ける
注意 これはあくまでも心を清らかにするため
ためと人格向上のためです
あの人のように金持ちになりたいではないんです
あれは俗世間のが あの人のように歌いたい
あの人のように走りたい
あの人のように豪華な服を着たい
あの人に地獄に落ちます
もうそれはあり得ない
それは業の世界です しかし
あの人のように優しい人間になりたいのは心の問題です
それはできます あの人のように怒れない人間になります
私の友達の中で亡くなったんだけど
もう何やっても怒らない友達がいたんです
もう寝る時間以外はいつでもニコニコ笑っているし
もう何筋で冗談ばっかり言ってるんです
同じ大学の教師やってて等でね
それでその人の友達がその人の散々お世話になっちゃって
その人に対して裏切り
裏切り行為をしちゃったんですね
そこで我々の同じグループでみんなより知っていて
これって人間としてはけしからんな行為だと
あなたのお世話してあげて
あなたにご飯作ってあげて
あなたに必要なものしてあげて
行きたいところに全部連れて行って
それなのにちょっとチャンスあったら
この人に対しては裏切り行為
これは良くないんだと言って
で 我々仲間でその人にもそれ言った
こういうことが起きたと
あ そうと言って それでまた冗談言って終わっちゃったんです
そこで私と真面目に冗談ではなく真面目に喋るんです
で しかし たまたま真面目に喋るんだけど
ほとんどその人はいかに私をバカにしてやろうかと頑張っているし
私もいかにこの人をバカにしてやろうかと
そういう仲間なんですね
すごい仲が良かったんですよ
はい それで私は真剣にね
何々さんに なんであんた怒らない？なんで一言知ってますよぐらい言わないの？と言ったら
あのね お坊さん その人に怒ったら
私に何か利益がある 私はこの残り日々もその人の面倒を見てあげて
その時日本にいたんですよ
その人は日本帰る時は見送りまでしましょうと
その人には気づかないようにしましょうと
裏切ったことは自分が知っているということは気づかないようにします
びっくりしましたね やっぱり
その人は在宅で 私は出家で
ああ すごいなと だからでしょうかね
私はあんまり人とはすごい仲良くはしませんだけど
その人とはものすごく仲良しなんですね
でも第三者にはそれはわからないんで
だって喋ってる お互いにけなし合ってるんで
だからみんなお互いライバルやと思ってるんで違うんです
我々は自分の話術を試してるんです
誰にうまいこと言えるのかと
はい そういうことで 俗世間はあの人のように金持ちになりたいという生き方で生きている
私は言っているのは 今例に出した私の友達に対してでも
あの人のように 二十四時間ニコニコで
明確に裏切っ 裏切られても
何のこともなくその人の面倒を見る
ああいう性格があったらありがたいなと
それはできますよ それはできます
それは心の世界だから
はい それで比較するならば
仲間になるならばブッダを選んでください
ブッダの前で皆様には威張ることは全くできません
極端に惨めになるんです
私もそうなんです 偉そうに喋るんだけど
ちょっとでも経典読んでみたら
ガクンと すごいなと思っちゃうだけで
だからあまり読まないことに
[笑い] 自分が惨めになるんだから
でも ものすごくありがたいんですよ
いつでも光を与えてくれるんで
人生に この講演の場合
作る時でも あらゆるテキスト
テキストはよぎってくるんですよ
たまに皆様に紹介しようと思ったら
この膨大な量になるんだから
もうやめちゃったんです
生命の偉大なる師匠は釈迦牟尼ブッダです
ブッダの弟子になることはオープンです
資格何も要りません これ
人間二人のコミュニケーションです
だからブッダが今いないんだから教えがある
ブッダが私の師匠です
終わり ブッダは師匠にする資格があるんです
ブッダは生命の仕組み
知り尽くしているんです
生命は何を目指して生きるべきかと知り尽くしているんです
それから自分でもやってみたんです
やってみてブッダになったんです
それを教えているんです
それからブッダのアドバイスというのは
だからすべて知っているんだから
完全です 最善です それだけではない
自分の性格に合う 実行しやすい方法を選べます
ブッダに弟子はたくさんいるんだからね
みんなそれぞれ業を持っている
互い違い人間でしょ？だからお釈迦様はワンパターンで
聖書みたいにコーランみたいに
皆なものよ 俺の命令だからこれ守れとは言ってないんです
各自で理解して 判断して
実行してください 実行してくださいとも言わない
あなたは自分が幸せを目指しているならば
こうやった方がいいんじゃない？と提案するだけ
あんなに優しい師匠っていうのは生命の中で存在しないんです
あれほど膨大な仏典があるのに
命令系はないんです 殺生するなかれあるでしょ
私たちはなかれと言うんであって
お釈迦様はなかれと言わないんです
他の命は奪わない方がいいよ
あなたは自分の幸福を目指しているならばと言うんです
条件付きで あなたは悩み苦しみを期待していないならば
他の生命をいじめることをやめた方がいいんじゃない？それは本当は業の法則ですけどというだけで
本人が自分で判断して自分を直せばいいんです
うん 面白いことは 誰にでも実行しやすいプログラムあるんですよ
誰にでも悟られる道 道があるんです
はい そういうことで堕落にストップする
次 それ ブッダの言葉から言うんです
ヒリとオッタップ これ漢字で惨妓と言うんですね
という二つの法のおかげで
世は問題なく流れているのだと説かれているんです
だからある人聞いたんです
なんで人間が獣なのに
世はそれなりに平和なんですね
みんなすごい欲があるんだけど
だからって人のものを奪おうとはしないんですね
お腹が空いたらといったら
突然誰かの家に無理やり入っちゃって
家にある全部食べるものを食べて帰るとかしません
あるいはスーパーに行って弁当とか作って売ってるんだから
そのまま取って開けて食べてそのまま帰る
それは誰もやりませんね
別に宗教でもないしね
何もないんだけど 動いてるんですね
その理由は慚愧があるからやと
ひりおったと 悪を悪行為を恥じる
善行為を悪行為を怯えることに真剣になる
慚愧っていうのはそれなんですね
悪 悪行為を恥じる そんなみっともないことをやるもんかと
例えばスーパーで弁当を開けて食べることをイメージしてください
そんな恥ずかしいことやめろよ
あるいは逆に こんな店の店員に見つけたら
もうどうなるかわからないでしょう
プライドはこんなぐらいになるでしょう
これが人が幸福になる正しいプライドです
俗世間は 俗世間はまた反対ですよ
善を恥じるんです 電車で体の弱い人に席を譲することはちょっと恥じるんですね
なんかちょっとという思っちゃうんです
人を助けること ボランティアやることは
そんなの面倒くさいもんということで
それから善を嫌がる存在です
世間の真似ではないんです
だからここで言っているのは
ブッダの指導なんです
だから慚愧は世の中にもありますけど
我々はブッダの教える慚愧を実践してみるんです
それで堕落は直ちにストップするんです
人の 次に好かれる人間になる
それには方法 4つです
1 ダンマ施しですね それは何とか人を助けるようにするんです
仕事をして給料をもらうことは
厳密に言って施しにならないんです
私の仕事で会社が助かっているでしょう
当然そうでしょう だから会社が給料を払っているでしょうにと
この施しのそうじゃなくて
公園をきれいにしてあげる
誰も金くれないんですね
そういうプラスアルファのことなんです
被害を受けたところにちょっと暇を取って行って
何かできることをやってあげてくる
そんな感じ  2番目ペイエバッジョ
これは愛語ですね 人の尊厳を守って話すこと
ギャーギャーギャーギャー喋るんじゃなくて
聞いてる人は人間でしょう
その人の尊厳を守ってください
例えば子供が悪いことしたら怒鳴ってもいいんだけど
子供の尊厳を守ってください
この間 子供が私の部屋にちょっと泊まっていたんだけど
そこで私がやらなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様の人は あ ご出所は自分でやっちゃうんですね
私は子供にはできないのに
まあでもやめなさいとも言えないんだから
そうと我慢していたんですね
それで ２日目でやっていると
この一つのカップがこの石で彫ったカップで
インドで買ったもので
そこに模様があって気に入っているんですね
お釈迦様には水を差し上げるもので
そこで微妙にちょっと割れるような線もあるんです
もう石だからね この子はもう自分のあれで
これパシッと割れちゃったんですね
これはもう随分前からもうほとんど 年
年ものすごく使っていたものでね
子供はすごく怯えちゃって
私のところに走ってきて
こうなりましたよ 私はこれはね
物は壊れる 壊れ 壊れますよ
実はこちらにこの割れ目があったんだけどね
私はすごくうまく それ割れないようにしちゃったんだけどとかね
それで子供はニコッと笑っちゃったんです
だからそれでしつけも微妙にしているんです
物は使うときは気をつけましょうと
これから起きたことは別にどうでもいいんです
私なら上手だからね ずっと私は洗っていたんだけど
そういうことはなかったんだからね
と言ったら まあにぎやかに笑って
まあ問題は解決 子供の精神的に何にも問題なく
事は済んだんです だから子供っていうのはいくらでも失敗しますよ
怒鳴る必要はないんです
尊厳を守ってください
それは愛語ですね 自分の言葉で他を傷つくことはしない
３番目アッタチャリア利他行をやってみる
やっぱり人の役に立つことをいろいろやってくる
この場合は この施しと違うところは
この知らないことを教えてあげる
できないことをできるようにいろいろ
してあげる 例えば受験中の子供には
もう どんな風にした方が物事を覚えられるのかとか
その裏技を教えてあげたりとか
自分にあることは人のために役に立つように使うことなんだよね
利他行っていうのは あの
大乗仏教みたいな宗教世界で言ってる利他行は宗教です
イエス様は受難したっていうのは宗教で嘘です
受難してないんです ね
もう捕まって殺しただけです
４番目 サマーナッタタ
それすごく大事です 同時という訳するんだけど
生命は平等です 犬でも猫でもミミズでも自分でも大統領でも総理大臣でも生命です
この業によってバラバラバラバラ
ハチャメチャですけどね
本来みんな生命です その気持ちを理解してください
それで全て自己管理は完璧になるんです
はい 次 テーマにタイトルにあったのは自尊心という言葉があったね
私はそれにはちょっと反対で
自尊心というのは作ってください
今ないんだよと 自分とは貪瞋痴の無明の塊でしょうね
心の中 ありがたいものはないんです
心に聞いてみると暗黒で臭うんです
煩悩に対立する戦を行う
慈しみを実践する だからそれで輝く香る自分を作るんです
自尊心というセルフリスペクト
英語で言えばセルフリスペクトはあの基本的に澄みていると思わないでください
よく中を見るとセルフリスペクトできません
悪魔です だからそれで流れに逆らってセルフリスペクトできる人間になるんです
慈しみのある 思いやりのある
怒らない 自我を使わないというあの四つのね
項目を守る人間になったら
その人のことを尊敬するんです
我は他人も 本人も 自分が良い人間であるということで充実感を感じる
だから 最後にお釈迦様の一言葉で最後だと思う
アッターナンチェーピアンジャンニャラッケイヤナンツラッ kitan
もう二行あるんだけど
ティンナンマンニャタランヤーマンパティジャッギージャパンディトという自分自身のことを好きだと思うならば
自分自身を守りなさいと
その守りなさい 守り方は次の二行であるんです
若い時はいい加減だったら
中年になったら真面目に生活しなさい
中年までもいい加減だらしない人間だったら
後年でも頑張ってくださいと
あの四つを守って善行を行して悪行をやめること
頑張ってよと死ぬ前に
はい それで終了でございます
はい 今日のお布施の法政の方々方にも
神職の方々にも あの幸福が訪れますようにと誓願いたします
それからご先祖の様方にも
今日説法を聞いた皆様もたくさん得度しましたので
皆様にも仏法僧の幸福がありますように
幸福で平和で安穏で生きられますように
心は清らかになりますように
涅槃に解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
サードサードサード  えーと
ちょっとあの割愛ということなんですけど
まああの 例えばあの 自分が例えば自分自身を考えて
自分があの もし今死んだら
自分の奥さんが生活に困るだろうとか
自分の娘がまあ生活が高校生なんで
大学行ったりとか そういうのにお金に困るだろうとか
まあやっぱりそういったことっていうか
家族 まあやっぱり自分の家族を考えると
まあやっぱり自分は今死んだら困るなっていうふうな思いっていうのはやっぱりあるんですね
で やっぱりあとはまあ
どうしてもやっぱり自分が自分という自己を中心に
自分に関係がある家族って
やっぱり自分に一番関係ある存在だと思うんですけど
やっぱそういったところからなんかすごい
まあやっぱり生命っていうのはみんな平等だと思うんですけど
なんか自分に近い存在から
やっぱり本当に心配になってしまうっていうか
幸せになってほしいなっていうのがやっぱり強く感じるっていうのと
やっぱりあの うーん 自分がやっぱり自分の家族とか子供に対して
自分ができることを死ぬまでに
まあ少しはこの世界に生きてて
ちょっとは苦労しないで
少しはお金でも残したいなとか
そういう気持ちもあって
そういうのっていうのはやっぱりあの
自分のやっぱそういう割愛なんですね
欲とか渇愛とか そういう部分
悪い部分になるんでしょうか
あの それはあの渇愛から現れてくる次の感情なんですね
これを束縛と呼ぶんですね
束縛 執着 だから生きていきたいっていうことは
この我々はなんて言いますか
このそちらに 家族に 子どもたちに
いろんなことにこの投影してね
あの それで言い訳作るんです
もともと渇愛なんですけどね
だからこれはもう誰だってやってることですよ
まあ子供はまだ学生だから
今死んじゃうと子供が困ると
私は大丈夫だという態度なんですね
本当は私は死にたくないんです
そこで別な煩悩で束縛というものを作って
我々はなんとか正当化するんですね
これは誰だってやっていることですね
で それ悪いとは 何事も悪いとは判断できないんだからね
結局生命のことでね 問題は
あなたにはその義務を果たして死ねるのかと
それはないんですよ 自分が無理やり思った義務が残されたままで死ぬんですよ
だから一応気をつけた方がいいところなんです
いわゆるもう 自分が突然死にかけちゃったところで
子供が娘が来て あの お父さん
お父さん 行かないでくださいって言っちゃうとすごく悲しくなるんですね
じゃあ自分にどうすることもできないね
その場合は だから世の中はそういうものやという風にも理解しなくちゃいけない
当然 生きている間は一生懸命金も儲けて残しておいて頑張ってくださいというのは構わないんだけど
でも 全ての義務を果たせるかどうかね
果たせないよ 私もすごく親孝行したいと思ってたんだけど
仏教の人だからね しなかったんですね
結局は まあそう日本に来たし
もうだから親戚任せでね
それは悲しくなっちゃったんだけどね
母親が亡くなってるスリランカにいましたけどね
まあそれでも私は大学で忙しくて
もう兄弟任せにしちゃって
私はもうまっすぐさあって言って
いろいろあれやこれやとかアドバイスして
いろんなことをやっただけでね
まあ本当に親がいいやつを産んじゃ産んで育てたなっていう風に思っても
思ってもらえるところまではね
親孝行はしなかったんですよ
ね  だからもう果たすべき義務がいっぱいありますよ
あるんだけどね  できるだけのことをやってよ
それしか言えないんです
でも 仏教的に考えて これは渇愛がちょっと化けたんですね
執着に それだけです はい
あ すいません 質問なんですけども
先ほどあった無明についてなんですけども
以前長老は無明のことを自我の錯覚だと言っていたんですけど
ん？聞こえない  無明のことを自我の錯覚のことだって言ってるんですけど
その自我の錯覚っていうのは
こう 思考や概念から現れるものなんですか？それと
その自我の錯覚ということと
あの 何という煩悩の関係についてもちょっと伺いたいんですけど
はい だから無明というのは
このベーシックプログラムですというか
OS で言えばこのバイアスなようなものなんですね
いわゆる眼耳鼻舌身があって
眼耳鼻舌身に触れることは知識にする
だからいくら頑張っても自分主観でしか知ることはできない
それを知ることにならないと気づくことはほとんど不可能になってますね
それに名付けて自我って無明と言うんですね
無明は自分自身で出ていて何もしません
自分自身が作る いっぱい家来がいるんですね
それは千五百の煩悩なんです
だから我々に無明に気づくことっていうのは難しいかも
我々は煩悩に気づくんですね
その自我があった だからこんなバカなことをやっていたと気づくんです
だから自我が自我の錯覚があったと発見したところで
無明がもう破られてはいるんです
はい 無明に直接会うということはないんです
よろしいですか その質問で
ということは 何かこう
千五百の煩悩の総体みたいなものが無明ということなんですか
総体  総体的に全部まとめて
というのが無明  無明がそこを作り出すんですよ
無用があって それがこの千五百の煩悩を作り出した
うん なるほど わかりました
はい  あの おばあちゃんが今入院中
百歳近いんですけれども
おばあちゃんもう時間解脱してほしいっていうのがあって
で もうおばあちゃん まあちょっと見てると
解脱まで無理やり執着なくしてくださいって言うと嫌がるんで
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにとか
あと 今の自分ありのままに観察してくださいとか
とにかく夜中でも もう最低もう最低というか
まあ解脱まで関わらず夜か
あるいは天界とか そっちの方面を目指すのか
無理やりでも解脱 もう一切もうおばあちゃん何でも執着な
こだわらないでくださいみたいな方向で強引に行くべきか
それはもう臨機応変なんでしょうか
うん そうです そうです
あのできる範囲でね 理解できる範囲で頑張ってみてください
自分で無理やり目的作ってあげる必要はないんで
それで自然法則ですからね
いや もう最低 おばあちゃまがね
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにって気持ちにでも乗ってもらえば
それだけでもすごいことやと思いますよ
ありがとうございます
はい  もう一方の方ぐらいどうでしょうか
停止していて あ 今おっしゃってます
como  今日のお話で主観というのと
あと人に好かれるために施しというのがあったんですけれども
昔カラスに餌をやると腐ったモグラをもらったことがありまして
ちょっと私には食べられない贈り物だったんです
同じように 私が人に良かれと思うことも
主観であれば嫌われてしまうのかなというところが不安になったんです
で 余計なお世話って言われるのが怖くて
そうすると あまり人と関わることを自分でストップをかけてしまうことになるので
その辺はどのように考えて人に喜ばれることを計画すればいいのかというのに迷いがある
アドバイスください  問題はこの人に喜ばれるようにするところに問題があるんですね
それは忘れちゃえばね
自分が人間としての義務を果たしている
恩返しをしている 喜ぶか喜ばないか
例えば公園のゴミを拾ってあげれば誰が喜ぶんですかね
どうでもいいんです そんなのは
そこに立派な善行になるんです
大体みんな失敗しますよ
たまに私も時々言ってみますけどね
私は全く使い余地もない
使うことはあり得ないものとかね
教えてくれたりしてね
これどうしましょう 処分もできなくなっちゃってというね
あることはあるんだけどね
でも私はその人は一生懸命考えてだろうということをしますけどね
だから研究してください
その辺でどんなことをしたら
こういう人々の役に立つのかどうかね
自分の主観の判断ではなくてね
だからこのそれで智慧が現れてほしいんだからね
だから ただの好意だけに凝り固まることではないんだから
そういうふうに この まあいろいろ研究しながら
微妙に相手にも聞きながら
ちょこちょことデータ取ったりしてね
そういうふうにした方がいいんじゃないかなとね
なるほど 頑張ります ありがとうございます
では そろそろ時間ですが
よろしいでしょうか では
少し時間なので終了したいと思います
では 最後の誓願を唱えましょう
ドゥッカッパッターチェミンドゥッカ
バーヤンパンターチェニンバーヤー
スーカンパンターチェニスソーカー
ホントゥサンデーピターニノー
苦しむものは苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命がかくのごとくありますように
はい ありがとうございます
内山先生 ありがとうございました
それでは これで本日の正法仏教月例講演会終了いたします
カンティーパラマンタポーティティンカー
ニッバーナパラマンワダンティーブッダ